There it is.
There.
All right. So, this was my this was my
answer back to her.
And so, we're talking about end counts.
She actually said her end count. So, her
end count is n little h and my end count
is n little t.
Okay. And I wrote this mathematical
formula for her and I said, "This is why
I won't date you."
Okay. So, it was pure devastation.
I just I was absolutely like
just I was absolute destruction and I I
didn't even care. I just said it. So,
then she started DMing me. Remember, I
can't answer on on Facebook, but she
started DMing and said, "I know who you
are. I know you're the WA. I know you're
part of the black manosphere. I know
what you're doing. Like, why don't you
date me and I'll make your I'll make
children for you. I'll I'll have more
than be more than happy to make children
for you. And I sat back and I said,
"Yep, this isn't the situation I want to
be in.
I I just I don't cuz if this woman if it
me right now, my situation, if I have a
woman like this, oh, this isn't going to
be good later on." So, I just want to
leave Facebook. That's it. I'm done. So,
did could you guys understand
um the screenshot?
>> Makes sense to me. But that's me. I'm as
cra I'm almost as crazy as you. So,
but I'll but I'll move things on. I'll
explain it. So if NH nh is n count of h
and nt is n count of the. So if you
divide her end count by the end count,
you get another variable of of q1.
>> Q1 is still greater than the end count.
Then divide Q1 by deal's end count.
Again, you get N2. Oh, sorry. Q2 still
greater than deal. Divide that by deal.
Divide Q2 by Theo's end count. Again,
it's Q3. Q3 is still Fred and Theo. So,
either Theo uh party god has a very low
end count or she has gone through a lot
of people.
I could have continued,
but I didn't feel like it.
I did not feel like continuing. So, she
had to at least been somewhat good at
math. Like at least some degree because
it's a well actually that's like fourth
grade math to be honest, right? What
when I did
stuck I I was like I proven my point.
I'm just raging like three times. Like
this is absolute destruction. I can't
just I can't stop it. Like this is my
bad. So anyway, um I wrote that out and
then I was just like okay,
you know what? That's it. So that I was
talking about it with uh Chat GPT.
I showed I called Chhat GPT Daniel. I
showed him the exchange of what was
going on back forth and I he's like, "Oh
yeah, you're absolutely crushing them.
Like this is really bad. This is like
you're just being devastating." And I
said, "You know what? I I'm just tired
of it. I just want to use Facebook to
recruit more men to be passport bros and
to make six figures. And then I want all
the real conversation to be here. And
then I said why don't we have like our
own way of talking so that they don't
know who we are. So it's and you know I
said I instead of saying we have friends
everywhere why don't I say um what is
it? I know poor people everywhere.
And then they would just keep on
thinking that us black men or other
people like us are actually poor, but
the guys in the no would actually know
what the code word code word meant. And
dad Daniel was like, "You really want to
start a resistance movement? Really?
Just so that you could sleep and make
some children?" I said, "Yes, let's do
it." So that's how Balerica Yavin five
start.
That's why I I said, "Let's just He's
like, "You could just do a Discord." I
was like, "Yeah, let's do it." I I said,
"Here you go. Choco installed Discord."
He's like, "Yeah, okay. Let's do it.
Let's let's make let's make it." So
there that's why it happened. Um I
thought it was funny.
Hey there, Dennis. There you go.
You ended this kiwi.
I I want to go back. I want to see what
she's writing. I want to go back to
messenger and see if she's going crazy
still cuz she was going nuts. She was
like like just little catchy pat was
like as long as you keep it on the down
low and people don't know what's going
on. That's probably the most effective
way of doing this. Just just be quiet
about it. Don't let don't let people
know your password.
Well, they're like, "Okay, let's do it."
Anyway, uh that's why the oven five
started.
>> Um so I don't know how you guys get in
here. I Hold on.
>> I I see I see you guys there. So event
>> I'm gonna I'm gonna figure I'm gonna
figure this out and I'm going to um
>> work with Darien.
>> No, I'll make groups. I'll do it. I'll
figure I'll work first.
No, it's not. I will figure it out. You
got people who can work with you. Work
with said people.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Three people are Oh,
four people. Three people are offline.
Okay. Dax is offline. There you are.
Hey, Darien. See you. All right. So, um
I'll work on setting things up. Who is
this guy? What you're seeing to
revolution. There you go. Um I don't
want this.
I want to be able to do something a
little different. I want to, you know,
have a little bit of fun. Um, I want
also want an area where you guys could
be a little bit more expressive. I saw
the the direction that Alex Pettit was
posting. Um, I don't mind if he posts in
a certain way, but I was like, "Holy
[ __ ] I know what it's going to go." And
that was another thought that I had. I
also sold Brandon iron he was posting
and I was like why don't we just put
into a different area where you can do
say what you want to say I don't have to
worry about um you know regulators
coming and doing something to me
anyway I'm glad to see you guys here uh
we'll we'll make this work okay I
promise
we're going to get some more I want to
do some more customizations here I I
want to some do some cool stuff. But
yeah,
I'm kind of
kind of moving on moving out.
Uh anyway, good to see all of you here.
So, I got Let's see. We got here. Got a
lot of people.
Okay, 22 people. We got Julian. Hey,
Julian. How was your vacation? I saw you
on the non-Virgin Islands.
>> It's fantastic. I want to go back.
>> How much that cost for the for the
private island? How much that cost?
>> Uh,
let me see. All in for flights,
accommodations,
um, food and drink was about 22 grand.
>> Damn.
>> Wow. Okay.
>> No. Before before a week, uh, food.
Yeah, like you said, food, drink,
lodging.
That's not too bad.
>> It was real nice. I have a sunburn.
>> Well, or my skin is peeling.
>> Damn, there you go. That's That's
>> I might do bro down to the Virgin
Islands. That way I get US citizenship
and I get to have a jump base anywhere I
want to.
>> Oh, so that that's going to be your your
bad. It's
>> it's been running through my head for
the past few days.
Well, what's what's the uh what's the
rentals looking like over there? How
>> expensive?
>> Expensive.
>> Uh that Okay.
>> But I could go one of the I could go to
a St. Croy, which is not as touristy.
It's something that's only moderately
more expensive.
Okay. Okay.
But it's good to have that experience.
I'm glad you did it.
>> Yes. And I was not stressed. You can use
I use some points for stuff. Um
so it was nice. Real nice.
>> And I got points from spending on it,
too.
>> Yeah.
>> Rate it out of 10. Rate it out of 10.
How would you like are you likely to do
it do it again?
>> Yeah. The only downside is because it's
an island, they have um unique plumbing,
but they only have single ply toilet
paper.
>> Okay.
>> Huh.
>> Bring your own.
>> Now I know that. Now I know that. But
when I was going there, I couldn't get
like it took me a lot to just clean it
up um to TMI. But that was the only
downside. Everything else was on point.
like this.
>> All right. Well, this is good.
>> I like this. I mean, I I I've never
rented my own private island, but I will
>> I didn't rent the island. It's private.
This is private.
>> So, how did you what did you do you have
any changing of thinking or process in
your brain when you did this? When you
actually did the entire process like
what were you thinking about life and
yourself?
Uh,
I wanted to do a vacation, but
everything I saw was like um too much of
a cattle call. Um, way too much stuff.
And I realized like price discrimination
could be a thing I could look for. So, I
was looking for more like I was looking
for price. I was looking for remote. And
then I saw this pop up maybe on
Instagram and I was like, "Huh." And I
started looking into it and I found,
let's see, I found the price to be, it
was high, but then I found a discount
code using AI, which is cool. Um, and
then
I did some track, you know, Google
flights and I was like, [ __ ] I get a
pretty good uh business class trip here
because it's offseason technically.
And then
I booked it. I was like, [ __ ] it. just
do it.
>> It's it's it's a lot because it's
>> good. Good. I'm impressed actually.
>> Yeah. Oh, good. I mean, I would say on
the whole island, there was more staff
than there were guests.
Like
>> good.
>> I would say 20 rooms
and maybe half of them were half people.
Probably five of them out of this one.
So, you see like five other couples,
small families,
um, newly weds, like you know, the wife
is pres pregnant pregnant, so she's
getting like a push gift or something
like that, that type of thing.
It was It was dope. Would recommend.
>> How How blue was the water?
>> Very. And then the snorkeling was even
better.
>> Yeah,
it was very good. You see little sharks
and [ __ ] turtles and [ __ ] Saw a
stingray.
That's pretty dope.
How was food?
>> Uh,
I mean it was good. It was definitely
good. The breakfast was actually
included. Um, the dinners
the dinners would be the amount you
would get at like a higherend restaurant
in the States. Um, but the quality was
comparable.
So, you know, think like
$30 to $50, no $30 to $60 for an entree.
Um
20-ish dollars for an appetizer. So,
like, you know, it's going to cost, but
if you're going to like
Flemings or something along those lines,
you know, it's comparable, but there's
almost nobody.
The big thing was like it was peaceful.
There was like even the kids that were
on the island, maybe like two of them
kids, but they on the other side. Um,
but I will say this though. Um, so most
of the staff, not all, but most of the
staff were blacks. They were like, "It's
good to see some of us out here having
fun." I was like, "Yeah, that's how
that's how sparing it was down there."
Um, so they were very polite and
everything, but they were like, "Yeah,
we don't see a lot of black folks on
this island." I was like, "Damn.
So, so they want to see black people
winning? What?
>> No way.
>> I thought that I thought that was a a
force, a fairy tale. No way.
>> Well, I don't know what the white staff
said. I'm saying this is the black
staff. Like, yeah, we had some bad [ __ ]
happen with that Epste stuff a couple
years back. So, we're lot more careful
about the politicians who we trust to
loan out, you know, properties like that
island, right? That's how Epste bought
these islands. Um, they're like, "We
know that some of the whites can be a
little weird, so you got to be a little
careful." It was It was interesting.
>> I thought I thought that cuz you're
black in the US. The black tax is
global. What? No way.
>> I mean, I didn't tell my I didn't tell
my family what I what I paid for this
[ __ ] I didn't even tell them where I
went. I just showed them a couple of
pictures.
>> Right. But but not not the black tax in
that you have to play more, but the
black tax that you got to do more for
the same [ __ ] but like no, you're
treated like one of the one of the
people over there and you make you get
special because you know, you know what
I love?
>> When I got when I got to I got off the
what do you call it? The taxi service,
the limo, and they were like, "Uh, what
would you like when you get there, Mr.
Williams?" Everybody called me Mr.
Williams the entire time. Felt
fantastic.
That's what I want.
>> Mr. Williams, water or rum drink? Mr.
Williams, how can we help you, Mr.
Williams? I'm like, that's Yeah, that's
I I I like that that I got him.
>> So, you know, okay, so now you know
what's Okay, good. So, it's I would say
like
um spending that much money versus that
type of time, it's you're doing it for
another reason.
And when you come back, especially over
time, that reason's got to compound. And
that'll help really socialize you. Like
that's what it did to me. And I my brain
changed from then on. I was like, "Oh
yeah, I know what's going on."
>> So um just started thinking differently
like how how do I stay in that world?
What do I need?
>> Uh Kubernetes. That's what that's how
I'm saying in that world. I got to learn
it.
>> No, it's not.
>> No, you know what I mean? Like I have to
I have to keep my mindset right, my
health right, my
>> think of it like this. You need to have
a system in place whereby people are
paying a certain amount a month per
month for Kubernetes for support and
then you're dealing with a different
kind of another process in there to
support the Kubernetes whereby
>> just get part of the cash flow and then
the process pays for your experience. So
then it's free. You're just setting up.
>> Okay. So you're talking about
investments that are kicking out
dividends to cover it.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> that's what that's where your that's
where your mind's going to go
eventually. It's just like what process
can I put in place that is one of them,
but
>> get this to
>> Yeah.
>> to get this to be something that's a
perpetual motion machine.
>> Yeah.
>> So then it's no big deal then eventually
like like
>> I'll be back in a minute. I got to drop
something off.
>> Like I don't I don't fly unless it's
first class, right?
That's just the way it is because but
now it's like do I have a process in
place whereby that first class ticket is
free.
That's where I really that's where I'm
really thinking.
Um well getting closer to that. Yeah,
I'll get there. Uh anyway, good job,
Julian. I think that was very good. That
was very good process. I think it was
good that you posted it and let other
people see it. Um
anyway, um
to the people who got more people
joining, um I put my Discord server uh
into the chat. If you guys want to look
at that, please do. You want to join.
>> What
>> I'm starting to migrate away from
Facebook from various reasons.
>> Well, what made you I came in late. What
made you make a Discord server?
>> There you go. I'll paste it. I I I need
to know.
>> I I
made you story.
>> There's various reasons.
>> Well, I know it's a long story because,
you know, there's been some people that
have told you for a while.
>> Yeah.
>> Making it a long story.
>> So,
>> part of it is that me getting knocked
out of Messenger, not being able to
communic.
>> Didn't you get your other account back?
No, I'm I'm I'm using my other Facebook.
>> I could have swore I saw a read receipt
or something from the other
>> No, I can read it.
>> I cannot reply.
>> Oh,
>> yeah.
>> Okay. So,
>> so the main So, apparently it's a
twoprong thing. So, is that is this main
account getting silenced for whatever
reason? You can't talk on it
>> for whatever reason. Okay.
>> What did he do? Harass Black IT Network
or something? No, I didn't. No, it's
>> that was that was law, not the
>> There was no reason for that. And I
actually asked other people on read in
other groups and they had the same kind
of experience like they didn't do
anything like nothing like guys over 15
years like a messenger.
>> The was likely talking to the wrong
chick yet again
like going back and forth with her cuz
that's what he does for fun. And then,
you know, like I I'm hearing reports of,
you know, Meta and other social media
platforms now looking into what's going
on on with in these message chats and if
and and it seems as if if there is
discussions that are detrimental to
Meta's target
female focus, then they'll then they'll
start shutting people now and it seems
that deal like I I can't I cannot
confirm this is something that I saw
earlier today where someone were you
know on the way to someone else's live
stream that was streaming on like either
Facebook and Instagram they were shut
down because it was maybe I don't know
what was sexually explicit material or
something it was tagged as sexually
explicit but
>> it was just it was shut down out of
nowhere and
>> that's that's my guess so ifo's talking
about this type of stuff with end counts
to a random chick that knows who he is
and black man and all that then if if
he's not accommodating to that
conversation then I might may shut shut
his account down to put him in into the
corner. That's my guess.
>> So that I think that was I think that
was something like that. Um, but anyway,
um, like I I've been wanting to kind of
bring us a little bit more underground
for a while now. I have been thinking
about for numerous reasons and that is
because I want other people to be able
to express themselves if they want and
not be under uh restrictions
or um, you know,
>> send them over to um, what's that? White
men,
>> monitors. I don't want monitors to be
able to know what you guys are saying. I
want you guys to talk however the hell
you want to talk. The only rest of the
restriction I have for discourse is no
pedo,
no 18y old blow stuff. That's the only
thing I'll go after. Anything.
>> I'd add a couple more restrictions. I
know what you're saying.
>> Yeah, we did try that where like do
whatever you want in Baller Backyard.
>> Did it get that bad?
>> I mean,
>> well, we had to we look at it. There are
some things in there. It's always it's
always the 1% jewels. It's like a couple
>> bad things, but you know, just like with
just like with Theo and his Facebook
account, my group could go away, too.
So,
>> yeah,
>> one or two people is all it would take.
>> So, so we're going back to square one,
guys. We need to figure out a
self-hosted solution. Theo didn't want
to think about it because it was too
much working.
>> Not only did Theo not want to think
about it, he wanted to put his head in
the sand.
>> Yeah.
>> He was like, "I'm not listening to you
guys even suggest things. I'm not They
might even be good. I don't even care."
>> Yeah. No, this was like, "Okay, fine.
Let's we can do we can do Discord all.
Let's go into it." So anyway, um, so you
guys, there go. We have the Discord
server. I'm going to work on this.
>> We have multiple Discord servers, which
is crazy.
>> Yeah, I'm probably gonna have Yeah,
I'll have more.
>> Uh, so anyway,
>> one one last thing. Um, I will be uh Oh,
God, people are [ __ ] crazy tonight.
But regardless, sorry, driving, um, I am
working on building out a private git
server, how to do it, script it out,
and, um, I'll try to get that over to
you in the next few weeks. So, you know,
so a private git server. So, you know
how GitHub
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. There's a private git server fork
named get t like ga.
I mentioned it a while back, but I'm
actually
>> Exactly. So, I'm trying to build it out,
trying to get done on AWS infrastructure
and trying to, you know, get geta
actions running. So, it's CITD
privately. Um, so, you know, trying to
I'm working on that now and uh I I'll
keep you guys updated.
Um,
have a little having a little bit of fun
right here. So, anyway, got glad glad I
got Discord up. So, we'll see how this
works. Okay. With
Yeah. get one of the things I was saying
uh Erin is uh based upon game theory the
way I think the the things moving that
this is going to be a dreadful situation
for a lot of western women and I I don't
want to stick around and look at this I
I don't even want to be aware of it
>> um but we've the manosphere has
significantly won
so I don't feel like watching the cap
>> need more wins
>> yeah yeah this We're we're significantly
winning. So, I would rather post our
wins in a Discord.
I mean, I think it's better. Um, anyway,
guys, let me go ahead and put my Discord
server over here.
The
Yavin 5 came from conversation with Chat
GPT. So, this is a resistance movement.
Oh, it's No, I didn't want to do that.
Where's my git?
Okay, there's No, I don't want that one.
Okay. So,
um,
okay, we have a few options here for
today. Um, got this real quick.
I have to go downstairs real quick
because my dinner is slow roasting.
So, I have to make sure it doesn't burn.
It should should be okay. What are you
making us? I made I made fajitas. So,
I'm making the fajita meat, but slow
roasting slow like slow cooker.
Um, this great. Yeah. Okay, got this.
Okay. Um,
so I think we're at Sorry
again. I'm reinstalling stuff like I got
all kinds of stuff going on over here
right now. Um, so we have here we've
been doing um we did Cognto. That was
good. does introduction to M. And so
last week, remember last week I wasn't
here on Saturday and Sunday. Sunday I
saw you guys didn't have class. Did you
guys have class on Saturday?
Did anybody appear? Did anybody show up?
Anything happened? Okay, it's three-day
weekend. I didn't I didn't mind if it
was one way or another. Um, so we have
there's two sections on here that we can
focus on. Matters of what you guys want
to do. So I have arbback here. Of course
I set this up I think last week. No,
three weeks ago. So we have the arbback
walkthrough which is setting up groups
relative to lambda
or
um we have you can go we can go back and
work on this one again. And this is a
navigation um connection to databases in
order to do user tracking. Uh, you can
do one or the other. It's It's up to
you. But we're gonna have to do them
either one either way. So, I don't know
where you guys are at. I'm just giving
you guys option.
Hold on. What is this? What? Got another
Discord? Really?
What is this one?
Uh, okay. I'll look at that.
Okay. All right. So, um, what do people
feel like doing?
>> Because if you look at,
>> if you look at the where I'm going right
here, if you guys see lesson G, do you
guys anybody know what sore is?
Sora
sore.
>> S O A R S O A R.
>> Yes.
Yeah, that's a chat GPT or OpenAI thing
I think. Is it their uh images? I think.
>> No, not Sora like so. You mean the
acronym for like security? I think
automation is in there. I don't know
what the rest is.
>> Yeah. So, security
>> security operations automated runbook or
something.
>> Security orchestration.
>> I bet R is response.
>> Response.
>> Okay. versus
>> so what our what the um
um our mechan is going to be as an
AIdriven sword,
>> right? Very architected.
>> It's really cool. Um you guys are going
to love it. It's it's really wild and I
designed it so that if you guys want to
go to the conclave and you actually want
to present it or if you want to present
it to an employer, you can. So um this
is I put the the first explanation here
for it. I'm going to keep on doing more
explanations. I this was last week but
this whole architecture is is here
already. I already have it all designed
up. So we it does include IM without a
doubt. And so I have the Rback here or I
have the database for user tracking. You
guys can do one or the other. Um, so who
wants to do something? Who wants to play
with this? Anybody want to hear that?
Anybody feel like having fun?
Yes. Yes, Carlton. That's why I did it.
Of course.
Yes. Yes, Dax. Yes. Yes. There you go.
Okay, there you guys go. You guys are
you guys know what's going okay? So, I'm
just telling you I'm not just aimlessly
going in the weeds here and just giving
you guys crap to do. No, there's
actually something there's a lot with
telemetry and soar that's coming up on
the horizon and we're using um Lambda as
a model and then what we're going to do
is telemetry and uh SOAR again, but it's
going to be with containerless.
All right,
sound like fun. You guys want to do put
a one in the chat? Yes. Yes. You want to
do it? Yes.
You want to do it? Yes. Yes. Yes.
All right. Good. So, I have some I have
some fan clubs. Okay. Good. All right.
So, who wants to who wants to do this?
Yes. ETL. YEAH.
CARLTON. I Yes. Yes, that's exactly
correct. But that's where I want that on
the Kubernetes side. Okay.
I I I I need to have for rag. I need to
have Kubernetes for rag. Uh because that
there's a lot of things I need in there.
So yeah, ETL is my ultimate goal here is
to you're designing your own ETL system
with AI, right?
Okay, good. Uh who who wants to go? Do I
have any volunteers? You guys are all
quiet. I started talking about this kind
of stuff and you guys are all talking
stuff. Now, who wants to do like
>> Well, I just stepped into the class, so
I'll sacrifice. I I don't even know
that. Okay, I got my lambda pulled up
the repo.
>> Okay, so you got the lambda up. That's
good. So, you can either do the lab with
arbback or you can do what we did last
week, which is the user tracking. Either
way, they're both related and they're
going to be a part of the future life.
They're just another step in the in in
the in the book. But to help you
understand user, so user groups, this is
good for IM. What do you got, Rob?
>> How how about how about this? How about
you ask the class to explain
AM are back and it significance
especially in AWS including authoriz
including authentication and
authorization
and then if you get enough of a
sufficient response then you can skip
over the user group I am lesson you can
return to that you go towards more fun
stuff if you don't give a sufficient
response Then we double down on the
basis of IM and we do the user groups
and so on so forth.
>> Okay. So
fine. What is arbback? Does anybody know
what arbback is?
>> I know that's like a resourcebased. Is
it access?
>> It's an azure thing. I know that for
sure. But it's Oh, ro control ro based.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Rolebased access control. Okay.
So, this kind of access control um where
where did it fundamentally start?
Anybody know?
>> It'll depend on which group your account
is.
>> No, no. The idea of our
>> idea
>> active directory
>> that was it was active directory is the
one place where it was implemented. It
started before active directory.
>> I'm guessing it have to be on prem
before even cloud maybe
>> where
>> on prem I'm just trying to think onrem
on prem is just as your being on data
center compared to your house.
So Arbach started the ideas of Arbback
started with the orange book the US
military and one of the reasons why um
the orange book is such an necessary
point for starting with the CISSP.
Okay. So ARPAC is very big thing. So
there there's two parts in this and
there's arbback which is rolebased
access control and then you have DAC DAC
which is discretionary access control.
The two differ in that role based access
control you have a role and based upon
that role you get access to something.
Discretionary is you choose who gets it
yes or no. So basically for example
um
uh I say you could you could kind of say
like
how do I say this?
Okay. So, let's say like in our groups
we have I have admins, right? So, I know
I decided who the admins were and I give
them like pretty much full access
because they're admins. So, that is
rolebased access control. Other people
cannot have people join the group.
There's other limitations that you have
if you're not an admin. That's because
admins have a role and so therefore they
have that they have greater access
control whereas if you're talking about
DAC
DAC is kind of in in one way you can say
it's kind of like Berica backyard um you
can post as you want you can share
things as you want right it I don't
really pay attention to that I only pay
attention a little bit but you can kind
of you have a lot of flexibility and
freedom there um it really is a better
idea of of deck or if you make like you
have um G-Cloud and you decide like your
G drive right and you decide to make a
file and decide to share it with anybody
that's an idea of discretionary access
control uh you you are deciding who has
access and it's not necessarily based
upon their role it's just hey you you
have access to it here you go so with
arbback it's decided for you
with discretionary control which is DAC
you decide who has access they are two
different worlds
um intra is one of the best
implementations of arbback they say this
in a commercial way the US military has
arbback all the [ __ ] place
it's massive they have a very controlled
way of doing this yeah I have to start
calling it intro that's just I got to
get modernized you
And it's a sad day. Discord and Entron
one time and I re I reinstalled my Mac
as well. So,
and not only that, I upgraded to Tahoe.
I don't know what's going on. I'm
upgrading.
Okay. Anyway, um so this is what arbback
is. I think it'll be good if you guys do
do an arbback lesson. All right. So,
this is the walkthrough.
Uh hold on. Maybe me. There it is.
Uh, do I have here?
>> To be clear with them, I I'd say like
everyone should know you guys have used
Arbback from the very beginning of
setting up your AWS accounts.
like everybody has
well I don't know what we name it but
like a a ter T terraform IM user but I
think probably a lot of people use it to
sign in also to the AWS console that's
uh role-based access controls
>> all right so
>> before this
>> before you keep going into the lesson I
would ask one I would ask people to
answer one more question from you. Um
can they explain what the what the
difference between authentication and
authorization?
>> Uh hold on. Uh give me five minutes. I I
have to go downstairs. I thought I have
somebody doing this. Give me a second.
Right back.
>> Okay. Well,
that's no problem.
So I think the uh with authentication
that's that's more like on the identity
side and then the uh
authorization is basically the
permissions that you can attach to each
identity which would be like like for a
role that have an identity with the
permissions that be the authorization
side.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. I mean, but like kind of like
Carlton put it, not just the identity,
but proving you are the identity.
>> Yeah. So, so what would be an example of
um ident uh of uh
and yeah, authentication and
authorization.
So like like our cognto lesson where you
uh the the multifactor
authentication that would be the uh
proving you're the identity. So that' be
the uh authentication
and I I suppose
>> Oh, sorry.
>> Well, go. So, so you so you're saying
Cognito? Okay. So, Cognto
serves So, which one does Cognto uh
satisfy? Uh
does it satisfy the authentication or
does it satisfy the authorization?
>> That's the authorization.
Wait, let me make sure.
>> I keep flipping, man. It's the Yeah, I
think that's the authorization
authentication would be the permission
that that you do in
>> Well, Cognito Cognito as you guys have
worked out it it can do multiple it can
do multip it can do both. It it can do
both, but you have to specify incognito.
What are you referring to? So So you can
try again. What if you want you got to
be more a little bit more specific. So
what incognito
uh satisfies authorization
permissions?
I think I mean the cognto example is
nice but
can couldn't we just say like what would
be the simplest
example
of something using authentication you
guys use
>> I say a password passed directly into
whatever your uh
>> whatever is trying to verify the
password
>> username and password
>> yeah Sorry.
>> Hey, could I give a a practical everyday
kind of example?
>> If you got examples, then go for it.
>> Okay, cool. Your your driver's license
is an authenticator that you are who you
are. Your badge for when you go to work
is an authorizer. It authorizes you to
go into certain areas. If you ever have
to go to work and you get a badge that
lets you go into different rooms or
determine what floor you're on, that's
authorization. That determines where you
can go once you have access.
>> That's correct.
I would say your virus license is a
token from the state showing what
permissions you have on the red.
>> So it's a token relative for permissions
doesn't authorize you. No new
authorization built but permissions
>> your key
>> the keys to your car or your fob or
whatever.
Um the keys
>> it doesn't really authenticate.
>> No, but it authorizes you.
>> Yeah, it does authorize you. Yep. You
have a key who authorized you. That's
right. Yep.
>> Remember in this context when you're
we're talking about authorization and
authentication, it's a system that
already is designed to keep you out,
right? So you can have the driver's
license, but the problem is that it
there is nothing that stops you from
riding the motorcycle or driving the
truck, but in this context, you're
already immediate. It's a it's a implied
deny, right? So if you're going to be
able to have access to something, you
have to prove who you you are who you
say you are to even get access first.
And then the authorization is that okay,
now you're inside. Can you get you are
you authorized to get into this room or
into that room? So you're automatic,
it's an automatic deny first and then
you're allowed access in once you have
proven who you are and that you have
that certain uh clearance to get to that
another level like in the government,
right? So you can have you can be the
civilian and then you can be lower level
clearance then you can have secret top
secret and eyes only. Right? And if
you're not authorized at those security
clearance levels, you don't get access
to see whatever information or get
access in certain areas. So you have to
understand it's it's an automatic uh
implied deny from from Git and then you
authenticate yourself. Then you
authorize you are who you say you are. I
mean you are the level of access that
you have. Without those you're
automatically just denied. Period.
I'd also say yeah so when you get the
actual token you have to go through a
process like okay so
before you you get your driver's license
you have to go through a process to
authenticate who you are.
So that basically that times to prove
your identity. So you have to bring in
some other document, right? So that
means you're actually authenticated
first at the DM and then you're assigned
permissions after that.
But you have to go through a
authentication process first.
I'm liking what I'm liking what I'm
seeing. I'm just trying to bring it back
to driver's license a little bit more.
Just kind of drier, but you know, see
what you guys are saying. What do you
guys Let's see this.
Okay.
Um, do you have access levels or a form
of authorization?
Good. Hotel is a good example. Checking
hotel
authentication.
So, at the hotel,
you have to authenticate yourself at the
front desk and then they tell you where
you're authorized to go. And that's
based upon and so
once you're authorized, you have a room
key, which is a token for permission.
And that permission that room key also
gives you access to other areas. in the
hotel but they've already like you're
already a part of a group and they say
these are the objects that you to which
you have permissions
and based upon your role and they go and
give it to you. Yeah, that's and a hotel
would actually be pretty tight to be
honest because they they know which
rooms have access to which activities or
which areas. That's actually pretty
tight.
NSA. That's right. Champagne or Bana.
Okay.
Okay. Authentic proof of my author's.
Okay. Let's say other methods bare
bones. Think about Yeah, you can do
that.
Uh fingerprint scan can be considered
authentication.
Yep. Okay. Yeah. Oh, yeah. That would
work. not be a filter. Yep.
Yep. Okay. And the profile attached to
it concerns access levels. Yep. Okay.
Okay.
Well, so authentication is who you are.
Authorization is what you can do. Yeah,
that's pretty much correct in a
nutshell. Um, so authorization
is a part of the permissions
and so you're authorized.
you have received authorization, you're
permitted to do something. So, what what
are those permissions? There's a whole
list of them. Um,
so anyway, uh, if anybody really wants
to get deep into this, you can go read
the orange book by by the US government
and this is the foundation for
understanding um, I would say not only
intra like fundamentally um, but also
how the American government does access
control. And if you if you understand
the US government then like
understanding intra simple. It's like
wow this is
it's so so simple it's not even a
problem. All right. Um
so let's see what we can do. I don't I
have the read me here. I did not put on
the walkthrough. It's fine. I can go
ahead and um we can make groups on here.
We can do this. I think it' be fun. What
do you got, Dex?
>> Hey, Theo. I just wanted to highlight a
an easy pocket example anyone can use.
Um, an ID versus a driver's license. A
state ID, it authenticates that you are
who you are on paper, that you're a
citizen
uh versus a driver's license, which um
authorizes you to be able to uh operate
a motor vehicle. It it also acts as an
authentication mechanism, but its
primary purpose, a driver's license, is
is to show that you are authorized to uh
uh uh drive a motor vehicle. I think
that's a really easy distinction anyone
can can have if they're having trouble
with this concept.
You see, before you get the driver's
license,
you have to authenticate yourself
to the government first.
And you do that with a with a birth
certificate. Usually
if you don't authenticate who you are,
then why how does the government know
that they can authenticate you? Because
it stands on something else.
It doesn't the the state is not the
authenticator.
Well,
okay. The DMV think about this real
quick. The DMV is not the authenticator,
not the main authenticator. It's a
secondary or a trinitary authenticator,
but not the primary.
>> Are we about to start talking about some
sovereign citizen [ __ ]
>> Yeah. Yeah. This is this is where you
get into some nitty-g gritties here. And
that's because when you're you have to
think like you're five years old, like
how do you authenticate
who you are when you're five? cuz right
well you the state can't give a any ID
to you so you even a 5-year-old has a
right to a birth certificate right it's
true they get this you has the right to
have access to birth certificate
so the birth certificate is the primary
authentication
without it you cannot establish identity
and this is Actually,
I'm I'm actually rather pro using these
kind of mechanisms for voting. It it
actually makes a lot of sense to me not
using the state DMV because the state
DMV can be circumvented.
Why? Uh because they want people
driving. So, when I was in California, I
was well aware that I did not have to
use a picture ID or uh even a birth
certificate in order to establish
identity.
That's a very bad move
because then the state becomes the
primary authenticator. The DMV becomes
the primary authenticator and that is
a problem.
The state has the DMV has its own
purposes, its own it doesn't say
or it has its own motivation.
Um I'm not entirely pro this to be
honest. Um, this I'm coming from a
Japanese point because Japanese do not
play about this. You have to have a
registration and a local I forgot what
it's called, but the local government
has got to have a a paper trail of who
you are and you have to have a stamp in
order to establish your identity. They
are not playing
>> they can go through your register art or
Yeah. Same way in China they can go
through your your family history for
like a thousand years many times. So
they they can go through the whole
thing. Yeah. Incon. That's right. You
have to have income. So when I was in
Japan, I had an income.
But even my income was a secondary
authentication because I had my my
passport was number one. But even with a
passport, that's not the United States
government. That's not primary. My birth
certificate was primary. I said it all
starts there with a birth ticket.
I know because if you apply for a
passport
and you use your light your driver's
license, they're like ah
that DMV can can say is anybody.
We don't know the requirements for est
establishing identity from the DMV. So
why should we give you nationality?
Why should we recognize nationality
based upon state document? doesn't work
that way. So, you have to go to a um
birth certificate, which is actually the
birth certificate is also state, but
it's it's a it's a basic level of
establishing your identity, right? Okay.
Why do I why do I get so picky about
this? Um because if you're looking at
role-based access control,
especially for US government, it gets
this very nitpicky, like very very
granular. and they are not playing
around. And this all this goes along
with roles and you have to be very aware
of of who is who and what role you're
doing.
They they go cuckoo on you.
Um
point for them to do that. Yeah, that's
that's I agree with that, Carlton,
because if especially like California,
if California had it that their way, an
illegal Mexican could just get a
driver's license, which I can't. they
have no problems doing this and then
they can just use that driver's license
to get US citizenship
and US government's like who like we
don't have a registration of you here
like who are you
okay
um so so accessbased control so um uh
hold on uh Rob what you got
>> well in addition to how important this
is and why we're talking about and also
why I asked you to elaborate on it.
Isn't one of your OG students uh
employed as a guy?
>> More than one. Yeah.
>> And this this is very much the focus of
uh seir one.
>> So the the GCP class with Azure this is
going to become a major thing in there.
And so if you guys are taking the class,
you can see what's coming down the road.
And this is a very major part in
establishing authorization.
So authentication is going to be a major
issue like how do you authenticate
somebody
like who does who is the authenticator
and you're going to have we have to go
into some degree of
what's it called? I forgot what it's
called. Um
what's the certificate management?
Anybody remember what certificate
management is called? Well, CAS,
certificate of authorities.
>> Yeah.
>> PI.
We're gonna have to do some degree of
PKI.
And so, just so you know, that class
probably will have PKI,
right? It makes sense to do PKI with an
intra
anyway. um go ahead and do this. I think
you guys can walk through some of this
with just the read me. Um we can need to
you're you're basically what you're what
you want to do with this is you're going
to make two groups. One is going to be
admins, one's going to be students.
students has access to the Python uh
lambda and uh admins has access to the
NodeJS and the Python lambda and then
you need to have two people uh actually
give their login information and then um
no they log in and then they it' be
automatically based upon their group
they'd have uh the permissions will be
set to which lamb they're going to they
can go
So, I'm going to walk you through this.
I think it shouldn't be that hard. We
have to make two groups in the first
place. It shouldn't be that that hard.
Uh, hold on. Um, yeah, guys are missing
a key point. This is crucial security.
If you don't understand the mechanism
before you you Yeah, you got to
understand the mechanism.
Yep, that's right. Denam deny is always
Oh, yeah. OpenSSL PTI. Oh, you guys will
love
that trauma.
Yeah, I did PTI. I cleaned someone up.
Oh my god.
Get yelled at. Okay. So, Kirk, you're
gonna be the one. You're going to be the
guinea pig for this.
>> Yeah, I'm cool with that.
>> Okay. Can share your screen.
You can set your lambda up, right? Yeah.
Do you have both your lambdas up?
Yeah, I should. Let me double check
cuz we're going to need both of them.
I'mma check everything.
Yeah, that that's Yeah, Erin, that is
that is true 100%
trauma. So, with my certificate manager
in the cloud is supposed to solve that
problem, but in data centers, oh my god.
Yeah, like EKS would like handle it all,
but like it's because it's all for the
CKA prep. It's using cube admin and
there's searchs for everything.
>> Yeah, there are you have hundreds of
searchs that you have to worry about.
They're expiration.
So, you have device communication, you
have external communication,
which will pain in the ass. You have to
be aware they when they're going to you
have to schedule when they're going to
be the searchs are going to be rotated.
So in the cloud you just have that
management. It makes a lot of sense.
That's one of the big benefits of the
cloud. People are like you save so much
money in the data center. I'm like are
you well in the cl in the data center
like are you sure about that? Because
just with management the amount of
downtime that you avoid
with manager in the cloud is huge.
Again, Azure does a great job of it. So
does uh GCP and AWS.
They do automatic rotation.
Love that. Makes
>> I still got my uh my API. I don't
remember if my cognito is on it. I think
I might have changed it, but the API is
still up there with the with the
>> We can make we can make pools.
We can make new pools. Yeah, we just
well we just need to make us two new
groups and then you're just saying one
group has access to one lambda and the
other group has access to two lambdas.
All right, let's just do something basic
there should be fine. Um,
there we go. Uh, that's right. Now we're
back. Right.
That's hilarious.
Okay, so we're talking about arbback
incognito. I'm going to walk you through
this because it's just I don't have the
exact walk through, but I can go ahead
and do it help you out with it. Um, so
go ahead and you're going to make access
groups. And first thing you're going to
do is going to make a um a user pool
within you make a user pool within um uh
cognto. Okay.
Okay. So go and create user board.
I get this right.
Yep. There we go.
You want me to go ahead and make the
test user?
>> Okay.
>> I don't think I could hear you.
>> Oops. Neither could I.
>> Oh, I you couldn't hear me?
>> No, like you sound like you're 10 20
feet away.
>> How about now? Better.
>> Well, seven feet away.
>> You know, you want
>> That's better.
>> You're getting better.
Do I want you one user that has access
to just Python and then make another
user who has access to Python and to
Node.js.
Are you sending it to a different email?
Uh,
>> I can I'll This is my first one. I I'll
send the second one to a different
email.
>> It's better. It's better to send it to
two different units.
I forgot the D. So this is being
All right, I got my two users set up.
You got user pools there. Hold on. Make
sure you got
Go to the user pool again.
Oh, there it is. User. Hold on a sec. Go
back. Go back.
>> Yeah, the uh the these two are from
another project, but this is the one.
>> That's fine. That's fine. Fine. Go back.
Go back one. Go to user management and
stop. Stop. Stop. Right there. Go to
left. User management. You got users and
groups. Go to groups.
Right there. Good. Create a group.
First one's going to call uh admin
and IM role. You don't have to do that
right now. That's fine. Go ahead and
create that.
And the second one um it's called this
next one called general
And there you go. All right. So, make
sure go into admin real quick. Go and
edit it real quick and click it. There
should be a preference area.
There it is. Preference.
Uh, put a preference value of one.
Precedence.
Oh, the trans. Okay.
>> Put a one there.
>> Okay.
And save it.
And then with the um for the other one
for general, go into that group.
Okay. And edit that one and put a 10
there.
Okay. Does anybody know why we're doing
this?
Okay. So, we're saying that the users
for the admin group have a higher uh
like how to say higher value. So,
they're closer the closer the lower that
number is, the higher value actually
have.
>> Yeah, that sounds like the uh kind of
like the priority on a
>> priority. Yep. on a knack like like
something that's uh stateless and you
have to uh kind of make it explicit so
it kind of
ranks it I guess.
>> Yep.
>> And then you leave space between them
too so you can add and put stuff between
it.
>> Yep. Yeah. No,
um go to users. Okay. Go to user
management to your left. Go to users
right there. All right. Now, so your
first person, your your Python, your
Python 2 is a general user, right? He's
only going to be for the Python. Uh, go
ahead and select him.
Should be select. Yeah. And not there.
Okay. Go ahead and click on his name.
Click on Python 2. Yeah.
Actions. Oh, group membership. Go down.
No. There it is. Add easy to a group
and put him in a general.
>> Good. And the next guy, put him into
admin.
>> Yeah.
There we go. All right. There you go. So
remember
the the big thing is that uh just like
we did in uh the other time when we're
doing IM users in AWS, you want the
users to inherit
the permissions from the group. So you
assign permissions to a group and then
the group uh sorry then the users in the
group inherit the permissions. That's
the easiest way of doing it. You always
assign permissions to the group, not to
the individual user. Please do not do
that. If you do
>> scale,
>> well, you not only can't scale it, but
it really goes to DAC. You're really
moving towards DACK. It really is. It's
it's a slippery slope. Um, it makes life
a lot harder because then you're you're
giving access based upon the user and
not the role and uh it can get nasty.
Okay.
All right.
So, you have the Hold on. You have the
Python Lambda,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Let me pull those up.
>> Done.
And so it's going to be these uh
Python lambda here
and then the no lambda there.
Okay.
Okay, good.
This
So just go ahead and add that in there.
They're actually adding um them from the
define
more thing there. So message hello
Python respons.
Yeah, you should be fine.
The only difference here is say
application load. So for the Python
we're going to be okay.
So the Python has that additionally
there.
Okay. You didn't put that in there yet,
did you? Okay. Oh, wait.
>> Oh, what do you what do you want in the
Python?
>> So, um the link that I gave you, just go
ahead and take it the definition lambda.
You don't have to do import JSON but the
define lambda. Go ahead and take that.
>> Oh, okay. So,
>> yeah. So, from line three to line two.
>> Okay.
Have a bracket.
>> Yeah, I guess that's all it is.
Might as well just so I'll take the
whole thing.
>> So am I adding it or replacing the full
code?
>> Well, you put the bottom.
>> Be sure.
>> Take that. Import
>> two definitions. Yep.
Save it. Yep.
All right.
>> Okay.
And then
Same thing for
the node JS1.
There you go.
>> Go ahead and save it.
>> Deploy it.
>> Get rid of that lines.
>> Yep.
>> All right.
Okay,
now let's see if it works. Uh user, so
the Python 2 user who is in
who is not the admin is part of the
general group.
Have him try to access the Python uh the
NodeJS lambda. See what happens.
>> All right.
Oh, I should
>> API.
>> The big thing is you have in the code
here. Let me get this right here.
Is the enforcement of the rule is in the
code right here. I'm put I'm going to
put this into the the chat. As you see,
it has if path node and and return to
SAS 403. And it says here admin.
The big thing is is we're looking for
the admin group. Uh so the only change
that we might do is is do you name it
admins or admin for the group?
>> It was singular admin
>> admin. Okay. Go back to the no.js.
Okay. And on line
424.
>> Yeah. Get rid of the
There you go. Save it again to
>> and I got to curl that with the I'll do
it in terminal. It's the uh
>> Yep.
>> pages
resource
here.
Class seven.
Oh, how's it going?
It's going to be
ter.
Where's my mouth? Okay.
I have to do the authentication.
You want me to do all that through the
CLI, right?
>> Yep.
>> So, you're using one user versus
another.
You should get for for the Node.js JS
you're for the student not for the
student for the general group you should
get a rejection
if you're using that use that account
I got my I can't remember the command
Remember?
Where do they
What's his name?
Do it this way.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hey,
homies.
>> Well, the API gateway is up, right?
Yeah, the uh because I have to sign that
user or sign in, authenticate, get the
token and then try to curl the uh the
route, right?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. All right.
Cuz when we did that uh
you gave us that flavor token Python, I
had to do a uh like a virtual
environment to run it. So,
we'll do that.
>> Oh, I got this here.
Yeah, I got this shortcut.
Okay.
I got to get my
godly.
It was a problem.
Sorry if it's taking a while. I I just
got to go back to my runbook.
Do these exports.
>> Take your time.
Go
>> rush.
>> I'm having a good time.
I need to use it.
What I call the guy
Did you mean to have that extra quote?
>> No. Thank you, sir.
And it's a dash.
Yeah, I'll slow down. Yeah, that's a
dash.
Okay.
There we go.
Not copying.
Oh, nothing. My Mac is acting weird.
Try to do it on my phone.
Okay.
Let's
take
Oh, is it
Oh [ __ ]
Share script.
Let me check. I gotta check that script,
too.
Okay,
now I got to change my routes here. So
there
ah yeah, I change. Let me just make a
copy of it instead.
Okay.
So, this is
Python.
That's not
Sorry.
Yeah, that should work.
Let's see. I didn't know you
update it. Okay, let me install.
>> It's not so hard. It's just
remember this could be you. This could
be 18 years with Kesha.
>> No, I'm good.
>> Everybody knows who your baby mama is.
And even though you paid child support
on time, she says you you're dead beat.
You didn't pay anything.
She's taking in port all the time.
>> This is just I'll
>> do not have requirements.
chat.
That is not
share scripts. No, it's right there.
This path
do absolute. There we go.
Okay, we'll try it again.
>> Hey, Logan. So you're what you're trying
to say is the general user gets access
to Python and the admin gets access to
Python and Node.js.
>> Well, when we're we're going through the
steps to do the the code for the I guess
initial authentication,
we use the username for the general,
right, for the first test.
>> Yeah. But to be honest, you just make
to make it quicker, just go in admin and
make sure you can go against node. If if
that one works, then you know that you
the copy and paste um with the code for
the uh uh for the change for the lab
actually worked. That's one of the
biggest things is making sure that
lambda actually works.
>> Okay. So start with the admin and then
try and access the the node, right?
>> Right. Yeah, that's what I would
>> Did you get the link for uh the node
code edition?
>> Yeah, I updated it. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> I got to go back. I set up that client
without making it uh it had the secret.
It's supposed to be I think like a
single page or something.
And uh I got to go back and do that.
Go back. That's fine.
my screen.
>> Remember, you get paid a whole day's
wage for doing this [ __ ] in office.
>> I can't just delete this.
>> It's not uh
it's not uh what is it? Uh not Julian
money yet, but it will be there soon.
>> I'm broke.
>> You could do this from the Virgin
Islands.
>> No. No. No. Well, he can do from Virgin
Islands. And based on Julian's uh latest
screenshot,
security, the security and security
one to 2% way off security. That's
pretty impressive.
>> There we go.
Oh, I could just log in.
>> No.
Uh go
>> go to menu
>> login on the left.
>> All right.
>> And then scroll down.
I think you
>> Oh, it doesn't have that page. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um create a style
>> and then just select that one.
Create.
That is in my room. But thank you,
Kevin.
>> Yep. You're welcome.
>> Yeah. Yeah, we'll sign.
Okay, it's working. All right. Um, back
here.
Set it here.
Ah, the settings.
No
here.
Wait,
I got to go back to my room. I have to
add that uh
that odd flow if it's in one of those
menus. Uh
Ar
here.
>> Yeah, it's in here.
That's what I
Oh, let me I'mma change these settings,
too.
Yeah.
15.
Okay,
there we go.
Okay. Uhoh.
No
ID. No, it's going to be a X.
This one.
I didn't enable the multifactor, but
it's just one less step, I guess.
Huh?
Did I mess up my script?
Curl.
broad slash.
Oh no, it's it's I messed it up here. I
got fix
slashno. It's class seven slash no.
Yeah, it's class seven. It's I I got to
fix my script.
>> Did you update your um Lambda with um
the right authorizer?
Yeah, he did that. He deployed it.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, it's is this here. It doesn't have
a class seven
and uh that that's coming from the
script which I have to update because
this has a class 7 node
and u
it skipped straight to the node here.
I'm pretty sure that should fix it.
It's open. Well, I thought I checked it.
I didn't check it.
It's going to be down here.
Python row.
I should just add it here though.
Oh, it's it's not just No, it's here.
It's class seven slash.
Pretty sure
I Yeah, I had to put it here.
That's what it was.
Oh.
run it again.
Well, I could have just put it on it
manually instead of doing all this
again.
There we go. Okay, now we're gonna curl
the no this one.
uh set up node query
execute.
Oh, I think it's it's not it might not
be taken in my
I might have hardcoded the API in that's
probably what this is. I got to check
this part.
What?
That's exactly what it is. I I don't I
exported it, but
I just hardcoded.
Yeah, I hardcoded here. So, slashprod.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oops. Okay.
Now hopefully this gives us it should be
a deny we're looking for right because
it's the wrong group.
>> Uh no you shouldn't have a deny
>> or unauorized.
So my Python user is getting
unauthorized on the no route.
>> Ah good. Oh so your Python user got a
deny.
Okay.
>> For node, uh, no, it should have access.
It should say error access denied.
>> It just says I'm not correct. Yeah,
that's general.
coming. That's the
>> Yeah, you're right. So,
>> yep.
>> In fact, you can modify that message if
you want to.
All
right. So I'm getting unauthorized
focusing here.
Um I think I got a think I think it was
what Kevin said. I think the uh
let me just check the authorizer.
Would that be uh here?
Yeah. Yeah. Let me I think I got to
update this
class 7.
It's the wrong user.
Mhm.
Yeah. That is it's what Kevin said on my
back.
I just updated it. This was
authorization class 7. I'll make a new
one
needle.
this useful
I just looked at it authorization
it's authorization
>> was Kevin's suggestion just to change
the user pool for the authorizer
>> yeah I had mine on the uh on the wrong
user from yeah it was from another lab
and I
>> Right right
>> gotcha Yeah, thank you.
>> And thank you, Kevin.
>> So, authorization.
Let me double check this.
Yeah, authorization.
And so, authorizes
class seven.
That's my user pool. Okay. All right.
Yeah, that's why it was unauthorized.
So, uh
this method
How to attach this
stages?
No, it's resources method.
node.
There it is.
Let's see if I create.
No, that's the the lamp part.
Let me go to my room because I don't I
don't seem to remember
off the rise here.
Okay.
A poem.
We have to attach it to the method. So
why did I Oh, is it here?
This is fine.
What I did there?
No, it's in the method.
I think that's it.
Oh, it's in the edit part here.
Yeah, it's going to be uh this one.
Okay,
man, that's annoying.
attach it to the note.
Python.
Okay, we'll try it again.
Know what that's Oh, I didn't deploy.
>> Did you redeploy?
>> Nope. That's what I'm going back to do.
Now we'll try.
Fingers crossed.
Last set note
526.
Well, we don't need that.
Everything
that's
Yeah.
Got to keep troubleshooting.
Oh no. authorization. Let me check that.
>> See this authorization?
>> Are you having issues with the Python?
>> Yeah, it's it's telling me unauthorized.
I did go back and
>> what was the name of your uh what was
the name of your group incognito? Was it
admin singular?
>> Yeah, my admin was singular.
If I remember correctly, I think you
only updated the admin
in the Node.js. I don't know if there's
an if statement in the Python code and
it references admins with an S. So, I'm
not I would imagine that would need to
be updated, too.
>> Yeah, that's good to check for. Thank
you. Let's see.
Just search. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you Logan.
So that's on the Python side.
This was in node. I was testing node.
Yeah, it's just one.
Okay.
Oh, this is this is a me issue now.
Okay. Turn the server.
Well, guess the user pool's working.
that that did mean it went through, but
if it went through and hit a issue on
the lambda, it's something I'm not
doing.
I think the authorizer is good. Um, we
got to check the L
here.
Yeah, that's the trigger.
Let's do a group verification real
quick.
>> Yeah, that is
>> I got a Python script train.
>> All right.
So verify groups.
That's not what I wanted to do.
I could just do code.
No,
Python.
Okay.
>> Well, that's one way of doing it. Okay.
I'll take that.
>> All right. And you just want me to run
that? Is it anything I have? Well, let
me look instead of asking
see if I have to edit anything. Uh look
for admin versus admins
and students versus general.
>> Yeah. Don't think that's there. Okay.
Yeah, you're good.
>> What's this going to do?
Oh, it's going to ask for my token
which might have expired by now. Access
token.
>> Yeah, you're fine.
>> You just want me to run this and uh do
the input?
>> Yeah. Yeah, just run it. You're fine.
Uh, let me get my token.
I just read it.
We'll just do it again.
Python 2
access.
Okay, we're going to take
that's the top
Does it not spit out the token?
>> Oh, I got to run that other one again.
Do I Oh, no. That's the
token is here. That's
Yeah, this is the token.
So, now we'll do
group access token.
What did I do?
Um, what it's doing it won't
control up and put past.
Yeah,
it's here.
That is my token.
Oh, that's that's annoying. I'm not
getting response in CLI. I have to uh
like after I pace I have to kill the
community.
We'll try this.
No, that's not production.
Let's try it again.
If I group this
Yeah, that's weird. It's I can type it,
but if I pasted it, it's kind of acts up
on me.
Oh, I don't even have it in my keyboard
anymore.
Is it
not in my clipboard? I should have put
it to the side.
Yeah,
that is something.
Yeah, I probably pressed it twice. Okay,
now I made sure to put this to the side
at the last 15 minutes.
Oh boy.
Okay.
Yeah. Did it
here. Okay.
All right. I got it to the side. So,
shouldn't
verify groups. Yeah. When I paste it
here, I I don't know why, but my uh my
terminal doesn't like that.
Maybe I could.
No, it doesn't like that either.
I've never really had that issue. Uhuh.
Maybe hard code it for now just to see
if I could get it to work.
What's the var
token equals? Okay.
Know that breaks a lot of security
rules.
Just going to try it.
Okay. So, I I got it to run when I
hardcoded this. I don't know what my
terminal is doing when I paste it. It
It's acting funny,
but uh yeah, that looks right. It's It
has the general group. I don't know
what's going on with the note route
though when I uh
when I try to curl that.
So,
let me try the curl again. It's the
because it it should get
what's the message?
Access denied. It's supposed to say
access denied.
That token is all
watching my curl.
But then
Oh boy.
Okay.
Yeah, that's my token
here.
Not ready to get
style. Remember to put this output to
the side.
Okay.
All right.
curl.
Yeah, I don't know. Oh, I should run a
test, but uh I don't think I have a
Oh, it just wants to name. That's only
document. I don't think
it's going to be here.
Yeah, I got this one.
Oh, what's the syntax here?
So this is probably
Oh, I think this was called causing an
internal server error because I I do
have a test.
It's a a runtime error, which I figured
because it's internal server
syntax error. unexpected token.
Yeah. All right. All right. Well, I'm a
step closer cuz the the test is failing,
which is why the production is failing.
Um,
I don't think I know what this means.
Yes, the syntax.
>> Oh, unexpected. Maybe I should use the
other token, but the pretty sure the
access token we need the ID token is
more general. We added the uh
the cognito stuff on there like with the
thing with the roll.
Let me open window.
expected to.
Oh, line 38. Is that what it's trying to
Oh, it's right here. It's right here. So
maybe
let me let me
Yeah, that that might have been it.
Maybe the editor. Let me redeploy it and
try.
>> Run one one more test.
>> Oh, true, true. Thank you for that.
That's what the test is for.
No, it's just
>> Yeah, that's the error thing.
>> Oh, okay.
So, so now that I got my typo out of the
way, we can try to find the real error
when
referencing error message event is not
defined.
Line 19 and 18.
event request context authorizer
window.
Oh, it's doing other stuff too.
We'll know where these over references.
I guess this is the line
14 10 32.
I don't know.
Oh, can't.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Really?
Oh, [ __ ]
Okay, there we go.
Whereas
That's a bunch of
try to see what it's doing.
Incoming. Yes, event not defined. So
incoming event
turns it to a string
name. That's a fallback.
That makes sense.
That makes sense. It's going to come
with what we added. Yeah. So, none of
that is
down here. All right.
Claims equal
is not to fine.
Question.
Let's
see.
Oh, it's stuff in the chat.
Oh, okay. It's working. I'm doing
this.
Well, not now.
working.
Hey Kevin, at any point you didn't uh
run into any errors with the uh with the
lambda code on the
>> um that is actually what I'm
troubleshooting right now.
>> Oh, okay. Oh, was that a different route
you tested with the access granite then?
>> Was that on Python?
>> Yeah, that was the Python one.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. I should probably test
that one. make sure mine works. At least
I'll feel a little better if it's half
of it's working.
So,
I'll try it just so I can have a Let's
see.
Change this here to
Oh, at least that's a small win. Okay.
Um, back to this note stuff.
>> Yeah. I was to the Thank you, Kevin. I
was to the point I was going to start
googling that error.
Yeah, I'm still googling.
>> Yeah,
a variable. Well, the constants are the
variables.
Pretty sure
planes, groups, path.
Um
event is not
reference there. Yeah, event. So
whatever was called event
or maybe I'm thinking about it the wrong
way.
Yeah, those are the variables. That's
what
make sure the variables in the correct
scope
complain about
is not defined at object
feature 198
claims groups.
Oh, is I think it's a event is a uh
variable
and and that dot is trying to reference
um
something within it, but it's saying
event doesn't exist.
And I don't think we have a
like a variable set up to define it at
any point.
Let's see this.
>> Yeah, that one is that event on line one
is what's needed. Um, but it's only
defined between lines one and 17.
If you remove the curly brace and the
semicolon on line 17 here.
>> Yeah.
>> And then if you highlight um events
after you delete it, then it should
highlight the event on line one.
>> Oh, see what's
>> But it's still it's
I'm still getting the
>> Okay. Yeah, that was a Thank you. Let me
undo it. See what I did. So,
Oh, that's here. Oh, okay. It was
isolating it.
Okay. Well, that's good to know
cuz that isolated this whole block.
But now, oh, but I thought I got rid of
the
Yeah. Now that's an error down here.
That's what I would assume.
>> Yeah. You just need to close the the
first curly brace on line one. You see
how it's red,
>> right? Oh, it would be
>> Yeah. So, it would have to
>> Oh, not with the semicolon there. I just
get rid of the semicolon here.
>> Oh, you know what? I did not.
>> Yeah, that's that's that's what it is.
Cuz cuz this is in the whole thing and
it'll it'll like
chunk it off like like if you do a
locals block and you close it then you
do another locals block. I think that's
kind of how it's treating it with the
semicolon.
And so if I just remove it here,
it's not going to close that whole block
until the semicolon.
That might have been that might be the
issue. Let me just
try it. Don't forget to test.
>> Oh, that is so true, man.
Oh, I got to put that in my hand.
All right. So,
we'll test it.
No, I don't think that
it right.
Yeah, let's update it.
Refreshed it.
testing
details.
Yeah, it's it's funny.
Oh, this is coming a bit too.
Now I'm curious.
Let's just put this back just cuz that's
how I
Oh, this is what I can do. I'll compare
them to see if they came out different.
I think it's the same.
Can we do this?
Oh, doing the escal.
Ah, good. You got the good message.
Good, good, good.
>> Saw the me. Yeah, I saw that for the
>> Is that towards me or is that towards
somebody else?
>> Uh, that's towards Logan. No, no, Kirk,
because you got the uh what is it groups
general there. So, you got that message.
So, that means the lambda is working.
Very good.
>> Yeah, just on the in the code. somewhere
is failing.
>> Yep.
>> Perfect. Yeah,
>> this is a second.
I think they're identical. Oh, I could
do actually a get diff on the files. I
could have ran that. Yeah, they're
identical errors. So, what we changed
doesn't matter.
Okay. So, uh yeah, it it doesn't matter
if you
take that or put the similar code. So,
oh, what can we do? Let me see.
Well, what's the event
incoming event?
Yes.
Did we look at the logs yet?
>> Nope. That would be smart.
So, we can see that
Let's
try this
event is not defined.
Trigger uncaugh exception error.
for
uncut exception here
exception
at option
19 and
That's
I don't know what happened to
I just
198.
It said it's not defined.
Not.
Oh gosh, I forgot a lot.
Oh, 1918 question.
Oh, that's what the test was for. Claims
and groups
not defined.
Add this object. So, I can't compile it.
Well,
I guess all this other stuff is
accepting
extension
It's a variable that doesn't exist. So
do we have to make that variable
or
is it
a reference system?
Yeah, it's being referenced here.
here.
That isn't me.
to a given name. Well, it's supposed to
be here or is that a function?
A new function to a given name. So,
that's defining a function.
No, that's this like
I don't know.
I see.
Oh, master.
I think
this close. No, these are separate.
Where does this close?
Oh, this whole thing is the function.
Oh, okay.
I guess this whole thing is a function.
That's called event
function called console.
Yeah, that's a function called
Wait, is it
The plan is equal to get function
request.
I think this is a whole function
that's named event or am I
am I reading it correctly
async function
Everything else looks the same.
event.
No
quer.
I'm going to try something.
Make sure I'm not going crazy.
Oh, it's twice.
And this song
Okay,
it's our new touch.
That should fail.
Oh, wait. Time. Oh. Oh, that that's
because I edited it. Okay. So, at least
I know the flow is working. It's just
something specific in the code. Okay.
Now, I just confirm it. So, is this part
down here? The second part that we
added.
Oh, it's saying
that 18 and 19. That's here.
I feel
good.
Amen.
Hey Kevin, were you showing that uh
something's deprecated?
>> Yeah, that's what it that's what it
looks like. But I'm not sure why it's
pointing to like the Firefox website.
>> Yeah.
on the edge.
>> Yeah, I'm on and it points to
um I'll up ping the put this in the
chat.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> thank you.
>> Yeah, you're welcome. It doesn't make
any sense why it's this.
>> Oh, okay.
Oh, so the property small E returns big
E.
Oh yeah. Yeah, that makes sense. Okay.
And then that's captured here. It
returns a value from there
uh which is undefined which is why it's
failing
outside of the context of the handler.
So it's trying to pass
a browser event into our handler.
Oh, that kind of makes sense now because
because I didn't see event defined, but
it's I guess it's passing it. So, I
don't know.
But if it's deprecated, it's undefined
when it passes it or
use the event passed into the event
handler function.
Event handler function.
Okay.
A shadow tree. That sounds cool.
So, how were you able to solve it?
>> Oh, I hadn't solved it, but I've
isolated it.
>> The uh
>> Yeah, when I uh cuz all I did when I uh
when you saw the success, I was just
testing if I comment this out here.
>> Oh, okay. I see.
>> And we just kind of isolated to lines 18
through 37.
>> Mhm. which the test kind of told us
already, but I just don't know what it
is.
>> Okay.
>> In here that's But it's it's that that
the part we added for sure is causing
the issue.
>> Okay.
Oh, wait a minute.
reading about shadow trees and
a
document.
Oh, I'll read that later.
handler function compatibility.
Oh, look at this. Wait a minute. Browser
compatibility.
Give another.
Yeah, I was able to get the access
denied on node.
>> Oh, cool. What What did you do?
>> I commented out everything um that we
have prior.
I'll I'll post
>> on top of it.
>> Yep. that um actually copy line one
because you're going to need that
>> the export.
>> Yep. And then that will go on line 18.
Yeah. 18 or 19. Yep.
>> Like that there. And then this is uh no
good.
>> Yep. And then just make sure you add the
closing curly brace.
Oh,
let me read what we Oh, hold on.
Is it something all together
different? Is that strange?
Let me understand why that works. Well,
let me deploy it first. Think about it
later.
Hope it's not.
Why am I getting access granted? I'm
supposed to be denied. No
general group.
I'm getting granted on my note. I don't
know what's going on with that.
>> Well, at least it's telling me
something. So the code is working but
the access granted on node.
Oh I think I put this
I got to check my routes.
So no
method request
what integration is the
authorizer.
Oh the
go.
Hey Kevin, on your uh
>> on your routes on your authorizer,
>> you did you use the same route with
these same scopes here?
>> I am pretty sure I did.
>> Okay,
take a look.
>> And
Python is the general crew.
Oh, did I?
Yeah, the user ad
I'm getting the
I'm getting authorization on both
like
that's Python. That's node
and that's Python. That shouldn't be or
we don't want that to be the case.
Okay,
let me look at the code.
If the path
equals node
and doesn't include the group admin,
which mine does not, it's general.
I should be getting next.
So,
admin. Oh, I I didn't add Wait, did I
Kirk Alton? No, I did. Kirk Alton node
is admin.
Ken Python 2 is general.
Oh, I gota I think I got to scope this
because it's that's admin.
Maybe this is general. I think that's
the
the issue here on the uh
the node is for I don't know because
that's already done. No, I don't think
so.
>> Is your node code looking for
um admin or ad? Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Access
granted.
Access granted.
Oh, I should have read thing here.
This is
Let me just try the other user. We'll do
that. Uh
user
know
Oh my god.
No, I got to go.
Go out. Where are
my ship?
No,
I don't feel like figuring that out.
Okay. Um,
Python flavor
C alter node.
Got a quick question. So is the issue
you're running into is that you're
logged in as the general user and when
you try to access the Python, you're not
getting the access denied. Is that the
issue you have?
>> It's on the uh general user or general
group trying to access the node which
should be admin.
>> It's so basically it's just letting me
into everything.
>> Well, I think the the node is supposed
to allow
the general.
>> Oh, and it's the Python that's supposed
to
>> I again I'm not you know at least when I
read it it it says path
equals slashnode and
exclamation point groups include admin.
So the exclamation point in my mind is a
not
>> right.
>> So that that would mean general.
So general should be denied node right
here.
So if if the path is node
and it does not include admin, it'll
deny you. So that means only admin can
get in.
So my general uh
my user in the general group is getting
in here somehow, which is a little
weird.
I hope that makes sense. That's right.
Right. So the P if the path is null
and it's not included in the admin if
denied which means you have to be admin
to get it.
And
that's why my it's up here somewhere.
It's a little weird. this uh
what's the python on this node here
route
I was uh doing it with the general user
a user in the general group and that
shouldn't be happening
>> okay
>> oh what's up Logan
>> no I'm saying I I use my general user
to access the Python and got access
denied.
>> Oh, okay. Well, at least you're getting
denied somewhere.
>> Well, I changed I changed part of the
code cuz like the if statement to me
didn't make any sense because like it's
a Python script, but it says if the path
is node, but it'll never be node because
this is a Python script.
>> Oh, I see. I see. I got you.
>> So, I changed it to Python and then
it works
>> because the logic was messed up.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, I'm on this node right now.
That makes sense for Python. I'll
trying to figure out this node. It's
granting me access, but but I thought
that looked right. If the path,
let me double check because I I don't
I've never seen three equals.
>> Yeah, I was thinking the same thing.
>> Yeah,
let me just change it. Like that's the
first thing on like maybe something I
don't know going on with this.
Java code or JavaScript.
Okay. Well,
oh man. Oh no. I think I still got
access. Let's see.
No.
Oh gosh. It's an internal server error.
So that that means whatever I did isn't
code isn't right.
Test it.
Yep.
time.
Oh, that's my 33. That's something else.
type here. Assign it to constant
variable.
Assign it to exports handler.
>> You may
>> Oh, yeah. What's up?
>> Um, equal signs.
>> 25.
>> Yeah, it needs three. I'mma look that
up.
Oh, strict. Oh. Oh, it makes it strict.
Check whether it's equal. Oh, that is
like equal.
Oh, no. That's Oh, okay. Okay. Okay.
I gota add these to my notes.
Yeah, seems like a coding thing. That's
probably
most languages. I've never encountered
it. kind of
distracting.
Yeah.
It is strict equality. Okay.
strict equality.
If path is
slash
node
and not
access the map
oh look look here this the
It's returning this regardless because
I'm assuming it it should be like a else
not a return.
So it's returning uh
>> uh scroll down.
>> Oh no, it would return both actually. I
don't know.
Um
>> let me scroll down. Yeah,
just entertain just to entertain the
idea. Add a semicolon to line 39
and then let's test deploy and test.
Thank you.
>> Yep.
However,
oh wait,
I wasn't getting errors though.
Yeah, it's granting me access. I think
that's the problem with my
man. I I thought that was a
>> Yeah, it's Oh, well, the server
>> Oh, that was different.
>> Yeah. What's up?
>> What I did for mine was I did not use
Chewbacca. I don't know if that matters.
Um I replaced Chewbaca
>> on your test. Yeah, with
>> the parameters.
Well, it would actually wouldn't it have
to pass the whole uh
>> Yeah. So, I'll paste what I
did. Uh if I can find
it.
See, is there a way to make this
look better?
Okay.
Delete this.
>> Yeah. So, instead of Chewbacca, I I put
the name of the user.
Oh, that's
That was a Wait, this is in your test
event?
>> Uh, no. So, this is part of my It's part
of my curl. I
>> Oh, okay.
>> Just because it's a um a character
limit, so I just cut out the the curl
already in the authorizer,
>> right?
So you did there
might make sense.
Oh, that's why my test is success.
>> Yeah, I mean that's the only
>> query. Yeah, it's
>> the only thing I see that's different,
but I don't that's
>> the we're looking for
Python 2, I guess.
>> Yeah, I don't think that matters for me.
I think that's because that's it's just
like a query. It's not a
>> Yeah, I think something's wrong with the
code because the Python works for both.
>> Mhm.
And uh it's just that node one.
And so I'm I was thinking maybe uh
cuz here this looks like it's outside of
this if
condition. So it's going to return no
matter what. always this.
It's not like you see it's not uh
>> not in there like that.
And uh
>> is does the indentation matter in
NodeJS?
>> I would assume cuz if you're doing like
a uh some type of loop or something
>> actually.
>> You see how this return is under that if
>> it's only going to do it for this
condition. But if it's if it's out here
like this, it's gonna return it always.
That I'm pretty sure that's why it's
always showing access granted because
this isn't uh this code isn't it's not
right.
So we we and and I think you need like a
else or something
>> and then this inside under the else and
then it's finishes that condition.
So maybe like uh I I would guess
JavaScript does a else. I'm pretty sure
uh else condition.
Yeah, if else. Yeah, pretty sure. So
yeah, we need a if else like that here.
And uh I don't know why it took me so
long to realize that.
So that bracket has to stay open.
Yeah, that bracket is going to be uh
open here.
If this return
that oops
and uh
is at the end of the statement,
but I know for sure the else is gonna
Yeah. Yep.
else.
Is that how we do it? Pretty sure.
>> I think you need to remove the um
semicolon from the F.
>> Oh, yeah.
And then it helps.
>> But it's still Oh, I guess you just need
to put something in. I am a tractor.
Let me
do my return that
if this
result
that oh you need to send my code after
your result and the return ends it. So
we're not going to return. will do a
result.
Maybe not. Let me leave it. Return
return that. And hold on
semicolon after the but that's wait
result
with result and return.
Oh, we need a semicolon.
Yeah, I see. I think I see here.
And then
else is with the if. Yeah, it's under
the if. Yeah, that makes sense. But why
not here? That's that's probably
I think the indentation's messed up on
here, too.
This should be here.
And then
else
I'm messing this up now.
Why doesn't it like that?
Pretty
sure we're getting close.
If
else
return this
Oops.
closet
semicol.
Oh, that's
a function though.
Yeah,
that is our path.
Return
this.
That's right.
What's
It does
under on line 36. Try uh the curly brace
and then
close parentheses,
comma,
and then uh curly brace,
semicolon,
and then semicolon at the end
something else.
>> And then I don't know whether you need
the else up on 30.
Let's see. Body.
>> Oh, you just want to return it.
>> Yeah,
>> that's part of the
>> So, access denied.
And then the next line, let's see.
Semicolon, I mean, uh, curly brace
semicolon 29.
>> Say it one more time.
>> 129. After that, um,
>> Oh, okay.
Uh, you've got your curly brace and then
a semicolon.
>> I need a semicolon.
>> And then the next line on 30,
put a curly brace.
>> 30.
>> Uh, yeah. Well, do a return and then
just put the curly brace by itself
>> or
>> No, not not
before the return. Just before I meant I
meant put a another line. Insert another
line is the better way to
>> No,
>> right here.
>> No, above that return line.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yep.
And then
a curly brace to close it.
Oh, go back. Go out a little bit.
What do you mean when you say go out
>> to the to the left one level there where
the
curly brace?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Not indent. Actually unindent and
go left and line that curly brace up
with the
>> Oh, right there
>> with the I and if.
>> Oh,
>> see if that works.
>> Oh boy. Okay. Thank you. That has
>> Yeah.
>> Oh boy. Okay.
>> I don't know that that will get it or
not, but
>> we'll see. I might have to
reauthenticate
this.
Oh, this is the Yeah, that's the
giving me access all day.
I think it's been more than 15 minutes.
Let me I'm just going to run it again
just in case
it's done.
Python
to
Okay.
I just wanted to confirm the the general
users supposed to get access deny for
node but granted access for Python.
Correct?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, I got it.
Um, I just used the the code that he had
in that repo
versus like adding it to the bottom of
the code we already had and then
>> replaced it all.
>> Yeah, I replaced it all and then I uh I
redeployed
the rest API gateway.
>> Okay, let me try that.
Eric Alton Py
paste
missing password. I literally pasted
that.
This is what I have for the general. I'm
about to test the admin.
There we go. Okay.
Put that here.
Thanks.
All right. So, let's try that. So,
this was
node R.
There it is.
access granted.
>> Yeah, if you do that, I think that
should be it should work then.
>> All right, I'm going try that out.
>> Oh, look at that. It has the export up
there, too, and everything. Okay. All
right. Let me just put the whole thing
on that. Let's
just do that.
Redeploy
redeploy this whole.
Okay.
So we should for Python
should let us in there. Of course,
no
denying.
Oh my goodness,
I'm still getting credit.
>> Are you you logged in as a general user?
Might want to
>> Yeah. relog in. I don't know.
Yeah, I should.
>> Wait, did you did you relog in?
>> No,
>> reauthenticate.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah, I did. It would be uh
well, let me do that.
>> Okay. Um,
>> yeah, you can just run that Python
script and then add the username,
password, and MFA.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> No, that is what
>> I did it. I'm sorry. My my brain struck
the uh
I did run it and Oh,
>> you got to run it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
>> I did Python, too.
And uh
I don't I didn't put the NSA on my user
pool, but
it was just let me
and I ran it off of here. So
I don't know what's up with that.
You go to your lambda real quick. Yeah,
I'm actually
add server open
do my Python
and my
Oh, is this I didn't fix that
yellow.
That could be one.
>> Well, you I think you might need to
Well, you can try it, but you might need
to redeploy your uh
>> gateway. Yeah.
No.
>> Wait, why? Why do you have a bear? What
is that?
after authorization
>> with the token.
>> That That's not part of the That's not
the token. That's I don't know what that
is. I don't use that. I don't know if
that's a MAC thing or But you should
I could try taking it out, but uh
whenever I was using this token, I saw
the documentation.
I'm not
>> cuz with mine I just copied that access
token to a variable
still
think it still needs
granite.
Still saying grant
that too.
Now it's saying, "Oh, what was that
doing there?" Maybe it's
maybe adding that caused the issue.
But well, it's not supposed to say
unauthorized. It's supposed to say the
message
>> is it a is it a Mac thing to have
quotations around your your stuff?
>> Not necessarily. It's I can take it out.
Well, let me
Yeah, I'll do it this way. take the
quotes off of it.
See, but that was
>> and then before the No, you want to
leave the quote for in front of
authorization
or No, I think you want to quote before
authorization and quote at the end,
>> but I don't think your HTTPS
needs a quote.
Oh, I see what you
did. Oh, I don't know.
Yeah, I think when I copied it, I wasn't
paying attention. You're right. When I
copied it, though, it takes it with the
quote there cuz my uh
uh I I have to fix the uh that script.
I might have put that in the script.
Okay. Um,
yeah, this is the part that needs to
forgot how to skip to. Anybody remember
how to skip to the end of a line? I
know.
>> Well, I think it's control on Windows,
but
>> yeah, control A goes to the top. Is it
K? Oh, K deletes it.
Uh, I'mma just copy it.
So, is this without without bear?
Okay, we'll try
and
take that. Yeah, that will make it
str.
>> Yeah, get rid of get rid of the bear.
I'll
>> do that.
And then we will
do it like that
still. Yeah, I think the largest
iterations are the same.
I'm sure
get rid of the authorization.
>> But Kevin, you got a map, right? Were
you able to get yours to work?
>> Yeah, I was able to get mine to work.
Um,
I used a single quotation mark for um my
URL.
Okay.
>> So, you put your uh right here on your
curl, you did a single quote.
>> Yes.
>> And then uh
take a look.
And I did curl dash I don't think.
>> Oh, that's probably
that Z that Zbash stuff. So,
>> yeah,
>> for bash I uh
Nobody use that
dash. You do single quotes on your token
too.
>> Uh, no. Those are double. Those are
double.
>> Okay. Okay. Make another
Let's get rid of the Y here. This double
here.
Okay. Let's see. There we go. Wow. Yeah,
that's a ZSH thing. Is that what that
is?
>> I always use I do remember the eye.
Yeah, I could just start a bash show,
too. Sheesh. Okay. All right.
But
>> Oh, wait a minute. Says unauthorized.
>> Yeah, we're supposed to get the lambda.
It's supposed to say denied.
It's still not.
Looks like all it did was uh change the
structure. It It gave us like this info.
gave me this in.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, you did good enough for now.
>> Oh, that's what the I did. It formatted
it.
>> I I have to go troubleshoot this because
you're having I have to figure out why
you're getting this message. So, I'm
going to work on this. But, um got to
admit, Kirk, I'm very proud of you. You
did very well. I was actually watching
your troubleshooting methodology and
your thinking and
you're you've really grown. I'm
impressed.
You can definitely handle an enterprise
uh environment.
>> Oh, wow. Thank you,
>> man. You can I could probably put you in
my company.
>> Well, I came a long way from touching
outbound rule.
>> Yeah. Touch. Yeah.
That's true. So, uh yeah, you did you
did pretty well. I can
you' be better than a lot of the Indians
trying to get jobs. That's for sure.
Kevin, you did a pretty good job um
supporting him. Also very impressed. So,
um not bad. Let me work on this. What I
like though is that I didn't have all
the instructions step by step. I just
told you kind of what to do and in the
office that's what's going to happen.
It's going to say to you what to do and
you got to figure it out. So this was a
much more realistic
office exp like replication and you were
doing pretty good to be honest. You know
you're like hey I got this I've this
message I'm going back I might this is
the process what I'm seeing. I was like
yeah pretty damn good. Um I'll write
some more instructions after this uh for
um what when's class next Saturday. So
go back to class on Saturday. Well, I
think you did a pretty damn good job.
What do you got, Logan?
>> Yeah, I just wanted to say I got it to
work in on Windows via Bash. So, I think
the code works like I post screenshots.
So,
>> I don't know.
>> Look, it must say that.
>> So, you got it to work.
Oh, look at that.
Okay. Okay. Good. Uh let me Okay,
>> but I did use your uh your your flavor
get token uh Python.
>> Okay,
let me let me work on this a little bit.
But at least it did work the way I was
supposed to, so it's good. It's always
getting good instructions. That's all.
Um again, I'm very impressed, guys. Um
enjoy. Go get a beer. You deserve that.
I know it's a I don't care. It's a
business day. Go get a beer. You deserve
that beer. Go drink a beer. All right.
>> I sure will.
>> All right, guys. I'll see you on
Saturday. All right. Yeah. See you on
Saturday. Johnny. Bye. Bye. Good job.
Later.